if we can just take a stroll to some of
your work that is incredibly surprising
that it works as well as it does that
launched a lot of the recent work with
neural networks if we go to what are now
called hopfield networks can you tell me
what is associative memory in the mind
for the human side
let's explore memory for a bit okay what
do you mean by associative memory is ah
you have a memory of each of your
friends your friend has all kinds of
properties from what they look like is
whether voice sounds like to where they
went to college where you met them go on
and on with what what science papers
they've written if I start talking about
a 5 foot 10 wiry
cognitive scientist has got a very bad
back it doesn't take very long for you
to say oh he's talking about geoff
hinton I never met I never mentioned the
name or anything very particular but
somehow a few facts are associated with
this with a particular person enables
you to get a hold of the rest of the
facts yeah earned or not the rest that
was another subset of them and it's this
ability to link things together linked
experiences together which it goes under
the general name of associative memory
and a large part of intelligent behavior
is actually just large associative
memories at work as far as I can see
what do you think is the mechanism of
how it works in the mind is it is it a
mystery to you still do you have
Inklings of how this essential thing for
cognition works what I've made 35 years
ago
was of course a crude physics model to
show the kind just to actually enable
you to understand my old tons of
understanding as a physicist because you
could say ah I understand why this goes
to stable states
it's like things going down downhill
right and that gives you that something
with which to think in physical terms
rather than only in mathematical terms
so you've created these associative
artificial well that works right and now
if you if you look at what I did I
didn't did all describe a system which
gracefully learns I described as a
system in which you could to understand
how things how learning could link
things together how very crudely if I
learned one of the things which
intrigues me as I reinvestigate that
system now to some extent is look I see
you I'll see you every second for the
next hour or what have you
each each look at you is a little bit
different
I don't store all those second-by-second
images I don't store 3,000 images I
somehow compact this information so now
I have a view of you which can which I
can use it doesn't slavishly remember
anything in particular but it compact
the information in those useful chunks
which are somehow it's these chunks
which are not just activities of neurons
from bigger things than that which are
the real energies which are which are
useful which are useful to you
useful disuse 'full to you to describe
to compress this information just
compress it in such a way that if I get
the information comes in just like this
again I don't bother to bother to
rewrite it or efforts to rewrite it
simply do not yield anything because
those
are already written and that needs to be
not look this office ever started
somewhere already therapy start
something which is much more automatic
in the machine hardware right so in the
human mind how complicated is that
process do you think so you you've
created feels weird to be sitting with
john hopfield calling them hot field
networks but it is weird
yeah but nevertheless that's what
everyone calls them so here we are so
that's is a simplification that's what a
physicists would do you and Richard
firemen sat down and talked about
associative memory now if you as a if
you look at the mind or you can't quite
simplify it so perfectly do you let me
backtrack just a little bit yep biology
is about dynamical systems computers are
dynamical systems you can have if you
want to map the bottle biology just want
bottle neurobiology what is the time
scale there's a dynamical system in
which you have a fairly fast timescale
what you guys ate the synapses don't
change much during this computation so
I'll think of the synapses fixed and
just do the dynamics of the activity or
you can say the synapses are changing
fast enough that I have to have the
synaptic dynamics working at the same
time as the system dynamics in order to
understand the biology most artists if
you look at the feed-forward artificial
neural Nets
they're all done as learning first of
all I spend some time learning and not
performing as I turned off learning and
I perform right that's not biology and
so as I look more deeply at neurobiology
even as associative memory I've got to
face the fact that it
the synapse change is going on all the
time and I can't just get by by thing
I'll do the academics of activity with
fixed synapses so the the synaptic the
dynamics of the synapses is actually
fundamental to the whole system yum yum
and there's no there's no there's
nothing necessarily separating the time
skills where the time skills can be
separate and it's neat for the
physicists of the mathematicians point
of view but it's not necessarily true in
neurobiology New York you're kind of
dancing beautifully between showing a
lot of respect to physics and then also
saying that physics cannot quite reach
the the complexity of biology so where
do you land or do you continuously dance
between the two continuously dance
between them because my whole notion of
understanding is it you can describe to
somebody else how something works in
ways which are honest and believable and
still not described all the nuts and
bolts in detail whether I can describe
whether as 10 to the 32 molecules
colliding in the atmosphere I can
stimulate whether that way I have a big
enough machine
I'll simulated accurately it's no good
for understanding but I'm just trying to
understand things I want to understand
things in terms of wind patterns
hurricanes pressure differentials and so
on all things as their collective and
the physicist the physicist in me always
hopes that biology will have some things
that can be said about it was are both
true and for which you don't need all
the molecular details is the molecules
colliding that's what I mean from the
roots of physics by understanding so
what did again sorry but hopfield
networks help
you understand what insight to give us
about memory about learning
they didn't give insights about learning
they gave insights about how things
having learned could be expressed how
having learned a picture of you a
picture of you reminds me of your name
that would but it didn't describe a
reasonable way of actually doing the
learning or only said if he had
previously learned the connections of
this kind of pattern would now be able
to behave in a physical way with the day
off I put the part of the pattern in
here the other pattern of the pet part
of the pattern will complete over here I
can understand that physics if the right
learning stuff had already been put in
and you couldn't understand why then
putting in a picture of somebody else
would generate something else over here
but it didn't out under did not have a
reasonable description of the learning
process but even so forget learning I
mean that's just a powerful concept that
sort of forming representations that are
useful to be robust to you know for
error correction kind of thing so this
is kind of what the biology does we're
talking about what my paper did was
simply enable you there love there are
lots of ways of being robust if you
think of it a diffident ethical system
here you think of a system where a path
is going on in time and if you think for
a computer is a computational path which
is going on in a huge dimensional space
of ones and zeros and an
error-correcting system is a system
which if you get a little bit off that
trajectory will push you back onto that
trajectory again so you get to the same
answer in spite of the fact that there
were things so that the computation
wasn't being ideally done all the way
along a line and there are lots of
models for error correction
but one of the models for error
correction is to say there's a valley
that you're following flowing down and
if you push a little bit off the valley
it's just like water being pushed a
little bit by a rock gets back and
follows the course of the river and that
basically the analog in the in the
physical system when able to say oh yes
error free computation and an
associative memory are very much like
like things that I can understand from a
point of view of a physical system the
physical system is can be under some
circumstances an accurate metaphor it's
not the only metaphor there are error
correction schemes which don't have a
valley and energy behind them but those
are correction scheme such a
mathematician may be able to understand
but I don't so there's a the physical
metaphor that seems to a it seems to
work here yep that's right that's right
so these kinds of networks actually led
to a lot of the work that is going on
now and you're on that works artificial
neural network so the follow-on work
with restrictive Boltzmann machines and
deep belief Nets
followed on from the from these ideas of
the hopfield network so what what do you
think about this continued progress of
that work towards now REE REE vigor ated
exploration of FIFO and your own that
works and recurrent neural networks and
convolutional neural networks and kinds
of networks that are helping solve image
recognition natural language processing
all that kind of stuff it's always
intrigued me that one of the most
long-lived all the learning systems is
the Boltzmann machine which is
intrinsically a feedback network and was
the brilliance of Hindon
and Sadowski to understand how to do
learning in that and it's still a useful
way to understand learning and
understand and the learning that you
understand that has something to do with
the way that feed-forward systems work
but it's not always exactly simple to
express that intuition but it it always
amuses me as the Hinton going back to
the will yet again on a form of the
Boltzmann machine because really that
which has feedback and the interesting
probabilities in it this is a lovely
encapsulation of something in
computational something computational
something both computational and
physical computational and they very
much related to feed forward networks
physical in that Boltzmann machine
learning is really learning a set of
parameters for physics Hamiltonian or
energy function
[Music]
you